our squirrel friend here likes to
collect acorns because really that's how
he is able to live and let's say every
day he collects exactly three acorns and
so what I'm curious about is how many
acorns will he have after doing this for
five days so one way to think about it
is every day he is able to collect a
group of three acorns so you could view
this as maybe what he's able to collect
in day one and then in day two he's able
to collect a second group of three
acorns in day three he's able to collect
another group of three acorns and every
day it's an equal number of acorns that
he's collecting on the fourth day
another three on the fifth day another
three and so if you were curious how
many total acorns he's collected well
you could just count them up or you
could think about well he's got five
groups of three acorns five equal groups
of three acorns
so you could say five groups of three
acorns three acorns and so the total
amount would be five we could view this
as five threes now five threes you could
view this as five threes added together
3 plus 3 plus 3 plus 3 plus 3 and if you
wanted to calculate this you could skip
count by three so this would be 3 6 9 12
15 because we add 3 we get to 6 we add
another third we get to 9 we had another
3 we get to 12 we got to add another 3
we get to 15 and so this would be a way
of recognizing that you have 15 acorns
but we're starting to touch on one of
the most fundamental ideas in all of
mathematics in fact we're actually are
applying it we just haven't used the
word and that's we are multiplying we
are using multiplication all
multiplication is is this notion of
multiple equal groups of something so
here one way to express what we just did
is we just when we said five threes
that's the same thing as five and I'm
going to introduce a new symbol to you
five times three so all of these things
are equivalent you're already used to
seeing equal groups and multiple equal
groups and you're used to adding
something multiple times and you're used
to skip counting and all of that is in
some way shape or form you have been
doing multiplication so when someone
says five times three you could view
that is five groups of three or you
could view that as five threes or you
could view that as 3 plus 3 plus 3 plus
3 or you could view that as 15 I'll
leave you there there's a lot of
practice on Khan Academy to work through
this and make sure you get the
underlying idea but as you'll see this
is perhaps one of the most useful
concepts that you might learn in your
entire lives